hello everyone and welcome today's live
broadcast optimizing the use of
laboratory testing services to improve
patient diagnosis we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab groups I am Julie
Taylor from the division of laboratory
systems at the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention and i'll provide
you some background information and be
your moderator for today's event then
dr. Michael la posada will provide the
keynote presentation dr. la posada is
the professor and chairman of the
department of pathology at the
university of texas medical branch in
Galveston before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green button located on the lower
left of the presentation window and type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen will answer is many
questions as our time allows but this
will be at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this webinar has been
approved for continuing education
credits please click on the c/e button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits thank
you now I'd like to begin with some
background information
in September the institute of medicine
published the third in a series of to
err is human reports and this one the
third one was published September of
this year and its title is improving
diagnosis in healthcare we feel that
this would be an important reference for
you to read because it's definitely
related to test utilization because test
utilization is a big part of diagnosis
another important point is that your
keynote speaker today dr. la posada was
on the committee that wrote this report
so we hope that you can have time to
download it and you can read it on the
internet it's available for free the
institute of medicine report published
in this report eight recommendations for
how to improve diagnosis and i'm going
to share with you three of them today
because they are related to our talk
today and they are related to our
program that we have at CDC to improve
lab tests utilization the IOM goal one
is their very first recommendation and
it is it states facilitate more
effective teamwork in the diagnostic
process among healthcare professionals
patients and their families well this is
directly related to what our program at
CDC is doing our program is called
clinical laboratory integration into
health care collaborative but don't
worry just remember the word click our
vision is that laboratory medicine is
fully integrated in the healthcare
system resulting in better patient care
and improve patient outcomes and the way
we do this is we have a team at CDC
focused on click and we also have some
experts external to CDC that are on our
click workgroup we have two co-leader
because we want representation from both
lab professionals and clinicians and one
of our co leads is dr. John hick nur
from the University of Illinois at
Chicago and he's a practicing family
physician the other co-lead is your your
presenter today dr. la posada who is a
pathologist each of the people on our
workgroup these experts help us with
projects and I'm going to share with you
today the result of these projects each
one of their projects has resulted in a
publication and i'm just going to
provide you with the references so if
you have time and are interested in
learning more about our work you can go
and look up these references on the
screen now you can see the link to our
click website the second goal or
recommendation from the iom is to
enhance health care professional
education and training in the diagnostic
process and that is directly related to
one of our programs where they recently
published in academic medicine
information about laboratory medicine
education at us medical schools dr. la
posada will tell you more about that
publication and others that I'm going to
share with you but I wanted you to have
the reference this is the result of
another program that we had at CDC and
click and this particular publication
highlights the work that we did to
understand primary care physicians
challenges in ordering clinical
laboratory tests and interpreting
results so if you want to read more
about it please go to this publication
and all the publications I'm sharing
with you today are available free online
I'm going to share with you just a
couple of bullets from this survey what
we did is we asked physicians how many
patients do you see per week and of
those patients that you see per week how
many do you order laboratory tests for
diagnostic purposes
and we found that they order lab tests
about one-third of the time they're with
patients which is not unusual from
what's been reported in the literature
but what isn't unusual is that they self
reported that they were uncertain about
fifteen percent of the time in deciding
on what test to order and they were
uncertain about eight percent of the
time about what to do with the results
or how to interpret these results now
you may think that doesn't sound like
much but if you calculate there are over
500 million primary care visits per year
and about a third of them physicians are
wanting to order lab tests and fifteen
percent of that time they are uncertain
you calculate 223 million primary care
visits per year which would affect
millions of patients one of the
questions that we asked physicians is
when you're uncertain about what lab
tests to order and how to use lab tests
what methods do you use and this is a
graph showing I'm going to highlight
something showing that they reported the
percent reported that yes they have
these methods available and that they
are very or extremely useful the percent
reporting so if you look in the top
corner you will see that we have
available and useful is trending reflex
testing interpreted comments they also
reported that they had computerized
physician order entry and when we asked
them whether they had that how useful it
was if it did not have electronic
suggestions to help them with deciding
what test to order and they said they
had this particular method but without
electronic suggestions they reported it
as the least useful but when they had
electronic suggestions with computerized
physician order entry it was although it
was the least available to them in this
survey they found that it was very or
extremely useful the third goal or
recommendation in the IOM report
ensuring that health information
technology support patients and
healthcare professionals in the
diagnostic process and thats related to
an article that was published through
our click work decoding laboratory test
names a major challenge to appropriate
patient care in this article we
recommend that there be some informatics
tools to help with test selection
another project that we have with the
click group is we develop some
algorithms to help with patients who
have a abnormal partial thromboplastin
time and then those algorithms were
converted into a application a
smartphone application here is the quick
read code if you have an iPhone you can
download this for free we are working on
getting it on to other smartphones at
this time but I wanted to give you these
references so that you can look things
up after dr. la posada finishes with his
presentation this slide has my email
address if you want to tell me anything
about what you're doing with lab tests
utilization or you have any questions or
thoughts after the webinar with that I
would like to turn it over to our
keynote address with dr. la posada well
thank you dr. Taylor and I'm delighted
to be talking to you today and what I'm
going to do is to weave the issue of
correct laboratory use of diagnostic
studies into this topic of diagnostic
error and what I'm presenting to you
today is not to slide deck given to us
as members of the committee but a
presentation based upon the slides I've
prepared that takes it a step further
the committee decided that a diagnostic
error is an
in which the diagnosis is delayed or
missed and that the and that the
condition is not explained to the
patient so when you don't explain your
diagnosis that also counts as a
diagnostic air there are other
diagnostic air definitions out there
that's the one the committee had in a
major conclusion from the committee is
that basically every adult American has
experienced the diagnostic error I think
the biggest question which is the one
you're going to hear at the end of this
is how many because it sounds like from
looking at the articles in the data
which i'm going to show you that the
number is actually far greater than 1
and in fact i took the the effort to
tell you about to organize some slides
to tell you about my own errors and and
you will see that someone who's my age a
60 ish adult has had has had many errors
so let's begin by by taking the first
slide it is that shows i have no
financial relationships other than than
my connection to instrumentation
laboratory as a member of their
scientific advisory board there's a
company that makes coagulation reagents
and instruments so there's the title and
and as i mentioned you before this is my
review of the 200-plus articles that
members of the committee read to come to
their conclusions you heard dr. Taylor
talk about click delighted to
participate with click now for six years
the goals are really the fundamental
challenges that doctors face when
they're trying to make a diagnosis well
what are the correct test that I should
pick and when I get the results what
exactly do i do with that answer so so
here's the outline of the presentation
we're going to talk about the big
medical error first and provide some
background information and then focus in
on this subset called diagnostic error
and as we talk about medical error i'm
going to set the stage with lab
utilization issues i'm going to give you
a couple of examples about what doctors
don't know and some of the problems
related to counting medical errors and
and then i'm going to tell you what's
broken and what the committee
recommended that we fix so what we've
known that's been broken for some time
in the laboratory other things you're
going to see here and we're going to
talk about the potential fixes as dr.
Taylor said finally we'll finish with
the percentage of Americans experience
diagnostic error and then some
perspectives so first medical error so
this includes all medical mistakes
treatment and diagnostic so if you have
disease in the right kidney and they
take the left out surgical treatment
error if they give you four times the
dose of chemotherapy medication error if
they tell you of asthma and instead you
have a clot in your lung a pulmonary
embolism that's diagnostic so let's take
a look at some of the utilization issues
in terms of cost obviously if you're
supposed to do one test to make a
diagnosis and you order 10 and the nine
of them are superfluous you've wasted a
lot of money not to mention delay the
diagnosis and a group from
pricewaterhousecoopers said that we
spend 2.2 trillion dollars nationally
and the unnecessary services are twenty
seven point five billion try seven point
five percent which is 202 billion and
when you think of the NIH budget being
about 30 billion we're talking about
taking seven times that and throwing it
in a trash can so when you think about
all the things that you need the
solutions for heart attacks cystic
fibrosis stroke okay we can't do the
research because that's how much is it's
being used in
unnecessary services there have been a
couple of reports and in this
presentation i'm giving you the actual
references so you can look at them you
can see in the PricewaterhouseCoopers
research institute report from 2008 it
was twenty seven point six percent
unnecessary another paper from Romney
are no in Boston 20.6 so it is probably
somewhere around that twenty five
percent value now what adds to it is not
over utilization always but overcharging
in this time magazine from februari 22nd
2013 contains within it this massive
article by Steven Brill and and he looks
at the chargemaster and says here's the
problem five dollars for one aspirin
tablet seventy dollar seventy four
dollars for a box of God's that's two
dollars in a drugstore twenty-five
dollars for the Sharpie that says we're
to make the incision the astronomical
prices for drugs are a big issue so when
we talk about about waste maybe you're
doing too many CBC's but we're not
counting that it's a five dollars in
reagents and supplies it it's showing up
as a hundred dollars that's being
charged so there's a magnification that
is associated with the overutilization
so clearly over utilization is a problem
but this is an even bigger one and
relates more clearly to medical error so
when you have somebody and you have to
figure out is this clot in the lung you
need a test for a d-dimer so in this
category subcategory of diagnostic air
if you don't order the d-dimer you have
been under utilizing lab tests to find
out if somebody has maybe a low
probability of pulmonary embolism can
get a negative testing it shipped out
the door and and what we've learned is
that if you consider how often under
utilization occurs it's a bigger problem
than over there's a paper that should be
2003 from
linen colleagues from the New England
Journal showed that for all the really
big things heart attack stroke cancer
we're only doing sixty percent of the
diagnostic tests that should be done and
in that same paper Romney are no in 2013
showed yup we're missing forty percent
so here here we are talking about two
studies ten years apart they're
basically say we don't do about forty
percent of the testing we should do
oddly enough in the same persons there's
an over and an under utilization too
many CBC's but you're not doing the
killer test to make the diagnosis so
what's happening is that in our
healthcare systems if you look at the
big yellow ball which is the total cost
to run your academic or non academic
medical center let's say it's three
billion only three three percent of that
is for lab tests and people when they
want to manage costs say what we need to
make that less so they get to the lab
because you can quantitate a reduction
in number of dollars spent on medical
technologist for example and so you get
it down to two percent the trouble is
now you're waiting too long for a lab
test result or or even a diagnostic
imaging study and maybe the answer to
really make the ball smaller you see the
yellow ball is smaller is to do a few
more laboratory tests because the under
utilization is so high so you can see
how diagnostic error fits into this if
we're not doing the right diagnostic
test first to figure out why you're sick
I just wanted to show you this one other
picture from the Time magazine article I
think this is stunning is it hard to
imagine that a baby born in Cuba today
has a better chance to become a toddler
than a baby born in the United States
remarkable that's the right side of the
slide and when you look at the left side
of the slide the United States is
spending the most on health care and
we're living the shortest period of time
and look at what's going on in spain in
japan right they're spending half or
less of what we're spending
and they're living longer so clearly we
got a systems there because I think we
have the brightest doctors in the world
we have amazing technology and yet these
are our objective data which we cannot
argue it so the cost is enormous to the
United States citizens from waste in
health care what about the impact on the
health well we're beginning to realize
that after heart disease cancer and
things like COPD the next leading cause
of death is mistakes now that's medical
error diagnostic and treatment but
that's huge it means that somebody comes
in they have congestive heart failure
their intubated they're not dying from
their congestive heart failure they're
dying because the tube that goes from
the ventilator pump to the patient falls
off and therefore the patient suffocates
the medical error issues which were
buried before now coming to the front
we're saying wait a minute that death
was because of a medical error so how
many people are dying from from from
medical error now when you look at the
first reports of number of people who
died from from treatment errors that was
to err is human there's about a hundred
thousand people a year and that alone
was shocking that you would get an
appendectomy and come out through the
morgue right but this one now looking at
everything and this is this is a
treatment deaths and errors in diagnosis
but these are two recent articles and if
you average them the one study is 82 160
so let's call a 120 and you average that
with the other study that says it's
400,000 deaths a year then we come out
to this mean of 260,000 deaths a year
it's really kind of remarkable what does
that number mean 260,000 give it some
context look at the next slide we lost
291 thousand people in the Second World
War so that means every year in our
hospitals we recapitulate the number
of deaths presumably preventable these
are error deaths now as happened during
all the terrible activity during the
Second World War so so this is a big
number with obviously big implications I
mentioned you already how challenging it
is to get a research grant for those of
you are writing them look at this news
so the NIH invest 30 point three billion
dollars in medical research for the
American folks and and doggone were
wasting 750 billion if you look at all
the causes which is 25 times the NIH
budget with these healthcare systems
issues so we can have a big impact on
what we learn about disease as well
let's talk specifically about diagnostic
error so it's a subset of medical error
and a lot of people would say oh the
errors are associated with bizarre
diseases you probably make a mistake
with maple syrup urine disease look at
what the mistakes are you know that spot
on the lung that's really a walled off
infection gets called lung cancer who
bad mistake the person who has
indigestion really as an acute MI the
hemorrhoid and the colorectal cancer
mixed up asthma and pulmonary embolism
all of these common things which can
cost people their lives where the
misdiagnosis are really the things you
run into the most when we talk about
diagnostic errors now there have been a
number of pieces of data to suggest how
much of all the air is diagnostic and I
wanted to show you data about a couple
here one is that this study which was
published in JAMA in 2003 included 53
other studies so this is thousands and
thousands of patients and it said that
if you take all the autopsies about a
quarter of them show up with a disease
that nobody knew about while the patient
was alive okay well that's one source of
data and it says
that diagnostic air is maybe twenty-five
percent of heirs now if you look at this
next one this is diagnostic air remember
can come from all picking the wrong test
collecting it in the wrong tube
identifying it incorrectly or just not
interpreting the test results correctly
so any place in there and here are the
numbers where people have studied about
diagnostic errors as a percentage of all
medical errors so I'm giving the
references as well but look at the
numbers in yellow you're going to see
how similar they are 28.6 for this study
from hopkins twenty percent for a second
study that was recently published in
2005 what about this next one comes out
to 17 and then 26 32 and most recently
50 when you average them together it
appears that if you take all medical
errors how many your diagnostic errors
it's a quarter and this is the largest
group so all the other ones are smaller
than twenty-five percent now are there
consequences for a diagnostic air and
are they serious this number from this a
British Medical Journal and quality and
safety to me in 2013 was stunning
outpatient airs at a forty eight point
four percent lethal rate I think what
that means is that too many people with
asthma or too many people the pulmonary
embolism are given a diagnosis of asthma
and therefore they think that it's not a
problem but they die in the next hour
and too many people with chest pain and
not considered a van MI because if you
make those mistakes that's lethal
mistakes and the air is for inpatients a
bit more credible but still 36.9 percent
dramatic right here two other studies
diagnostic errors were two times more
likely to lead to death or disability
than any other medical errors again
pointing to diagnostic errors as being
the biggest problem and the next piece
of data I can show you in this figure
which I'll show you next paper led by
dr. Gordon Fishman going shipment ship
in at in Boston and what glory did was
to look at the seriousness and frequency
of heirs after surveying the docks at
Grand Rounds about mistakes that they
had made so it's a data recall bias but
look at the one on the left it basically
shows that about a quarter of the ears
or minor and impact a quarter are major
and about half or moderate so there are
a lot of major consequences for making a
diagnostic error now one of the other
problems with counting diagnostic errors
which were just realizing is that that
that consequences of the mistake comes
come months two years later so what is
an example of that so from 1981 284 if
you had a kid who was needed his tonsils
out and the PTT was elevated which is
common in that setting and you gave the
child two bags of fresh frozen plasma
one out of 20 had hepatitis C or HIV so
the person dies four years later do they
attribute that to the transfusion from
the HIV or if they get a liver
transplant 20 years later from the
hepatitis C infection do they attribute
that to the air because somebody didn't
know how to work up a prolonged PTT so
as you see that the error may have been
made years before so that's an important
point that now has elevated the number
of people who are recognized as being a
dead from a medical error now it's also
unlikely that the ear nose and throat
surgeon said that's the problem that I
had and let me fix this now 20 years
later now here's the most dangerous
scenario of the mall and that is that
the doctors think they know the answer
but they actually don't and here's a
couple of examples this showed up in
JAMA on April 21st last year and they
gave doctors in the Boston area
scenario they said you tell your patient
that the patient's been screened for a
rare disease strikes one in a thousand
it could kill you and your test is
positive and the patient says is there
any chance the test is wrong and you say
the false positive rates five percent so
then they went back and said to the
doctors in Boston so what do you say
next and most of them said that there's
a ninety-five percent chance that you
actually have the disease nobody really
knew that the prevalence that one in
1,000 has a big impact on the answer
because the real answer is two percent
now if you were told you had a
ninety-five percent chance of dying when
the real answer was two percent and the
doctor thought he or she was right
that's a huge problem obviously here's
another conversation I had about a 22
year old lady who comes in with belly
pain claims to be pregnant and you want
to do an imaging study and you don't
want to perform an imaging study if
she's pregnant so I said to the doctor
what would you do and the doctor said
well I'd repeat the urine pregnancy test
to make sure she's really pregnant and
and I said which pregnancy tests would
you use and he said are they different
and I said yes some turn positive 20
days after conception some is late it's
dirty oh I didn't know that what a first
turn positive in 20 days and yours turns
positive at 30 days and she's 25 days
after conception oh then you're going to
get a wrong answer and you're going to
radiate the baby the fetus right so why
wouldn't you use the serum based
pregnancy test right so they don't know
they're making a mistake right and so
the urine based tests become positive
way later than the serum based test and
there are even some false negatives with
one particular urine based pregnancy
test the trouble is there's not a single
doc in the emergency room who knows that
so is there a chance that when a kid is
born without a right hand that anybody
is saying oh that was a diagnostic error
and we didn't know about your
impregnation test them that's a but
that's the reality of it that's exactly
what happened so let's talk about some
of the things doctors don't know when I
bring up
rheumatology so let's take autoimmune
disorders so you'd love to have somebody
who really knows this right so you go to
your doctor and you might have lupus or
rheumatoid arthritis or scleroderma and
so why would you have a non-expert right
so most patients think that their doctor
is an expert in everything right
especially if they're nice so here's
some data about rheumatology it turns
out that 23.5 million Americans have an
autoimmune disease cancer has nine by
comparison nine million and we spend a
hundred billion on autoimmune disease
and that's even more than cancer so how
many rheumatologists are there to take
care of all these autoimmune diseases
well it turns out that we are going to
have a big problem we're currently short
but but it's going to get a lot shorter
because by 2025 the demand is going to
be 2500 rheumatologists that we don't
have right and and so big problem so
we're not going to have experts they
can't sort out this immunofluorescence
your primary care doctor what does it
mean of its speckled and I'm trying to
decide between polymyositis and
dermatome Isis I don't know right and
which serology should I be doing oh boy
okay so it's not because they're not
smart everybody here is plenty smart
there is just so much to know right so
what happens when you go to a doc and
they have a you have a connective tissue
disease and the person has not spent
time in a fellowship doing this the risk
of a diagnostic error goes way up okay
so let's go to specifically to what's
broken and the fixes and what can be
done first as you heard from dr. Taylor
the committee said you need to have
diagnostic teams getting a diagnosis is
a team sport so one primary care doctor
may be able to sort out a diagnosis some
percentage of the time but man that
number of cases
engine cases is going down dramatically
as the test menu gets bigger and we can
do so much more to figure out a
diagnosis so many of you heard me talk
about what's called a diagnostic
management team whose goal is to help
doctors pick the right test and
interpret the test results so here's
what a diagnostic management team does
as you know what we currently do is we
throw test results over a wall here's a
picture we're on the right right we're
diagnostic people clinical lab
scientists pathologists medical lab
technologist and we just throw those
factor 5 Leiden heterozygous results
over at some poor doctor who can't
figure out what the heck it means right
and then they got 15 minutes per patient
but here's what a diagnostic management
team does it takes all the pieces and it
says oh you want us to do a
hypercoagulable any work up we'll put
all the pieces together and tell you
what it is and give you an assessment of
thrombotic risk so instead of getting
this muck here which is what was given
to doctors on june thirtieth 2010 at
vanderbilt where doctors have no idea
what these abbreviations for the
different tests mean right and instead
give them this that says your patient
has a prolonged PTT with a normal PT
normal trauma time we're picking the
test now because it's all algorithmic we
did a mixing study there was an
inhibitor the most common ones that look
at santa coagulant the test for it's a
russell viper venom and and yellow at
the bottom your patient who has a
prolonged PTT as God because there's a
lupus anticoagulant and they don't bleed
by the way so we looked at the benefits
of this on the x-axis is total charges
so on the right is bad on the y-axis is
LS length of stay at the top is bad so
the red is before Co a ground started at
Vanderbilt notice it goes all the way
from the left lower left corner to the
upper right corner right but when you
look at what happened after round
started the green they're beginning to
coalesce in the lower left we caught an
entire day off the length of State for a
patient with a Pullman
arey embolism with this diagnosis
related group DRG 176 take a look at the
next one intracranial hemorrhage this is
even better right so those bleeds in
your head those little pools of blood
they give you the hemorrhagic stroke
after the DMT started the green dots are
really coalescing in that lower left
corner major progress there were other
DM T's besides coagulation the
microbiology DMT managed to come
together and solve the problem that was
associated with steroid preparations
made in a company in New England which
were given to reduce inflammation often
in in the back when your back pain there
had been 730 cases in 20 states 51 death
and doctors rauch chapel and stratton
were presented with a case at their
microbiology diagnostic management team
and showed that there was aspergillus
fumigatus in the syringe the patient
wasn't immunocompromised it was a true
infection not a lab contaminant they did
molecular in anigenics studies told the
Department of Health what was going on
and in a month they were asked to write
a paper in the New England Journal of
Medicine how all that came together so
when you put a bunch of diagnostic
experts in a room and you're talking
about diagnostic air isn't it intuitive
that now you've got the potential
solution to greatly reduce it we've done
a survey when we did diagnostic
management team work at the Mass General
this is work with betsy van cott was it
the Mass General and myself and a
resident we did a survey we got 46 out
of a hundred back sent him a paragraph
that was an interpretation we had some
four questions when we interpreted it
for you did you get the diagnosis sooner
and about sixty percent said yes and we
said did you order fewer test because
now you're learning what the right tests
are to select that about three-quarters
said yes and then we said were you going
to make a mistake and remarkably about
it three-quarters of people said they
were
which is remarkable and then
ninety-eight percent said we like it you
should keep it I've often said that free
money does not have a ninety-eight
percent approval rating too many people
would complain that the gold was too
heavy to carry to the bank right so why
hasn't this been everywhere it's the
biggest question if it's such a good
idea right and i found this creative
people must be stopped calm website and
i found the answer first the innovation
must be a good idea I don't think
anybody disputes the fact of bringing an
expert to a complicated clinical
question is a good idea the second which
is a major stumbling block is that the
innovation has to be accepted by the
group the big group that is pathologists
aren't paying for this right so if you
have a job where you can get paid for it
or you couldn't get paid for it most
normal people would pick the one where
you can get paid for its right so the
pathologist's run the laboratory but
they're not so keen on doing this
activity and the hospital does not want
to hire people to be lab directors who
aren't going to do this because this is
how you get savings so hiring somebody
to quote manage the laboratory who isn't
going to do this is not in the
hospital's best interest so those are
two big barriers the organization has to
buy ensure the clinicians want it
there's a definitely a market need
society would support it except most
patients don't think there's a problem
and although it may be hard to do this
is still doable and you don't need that
much tick technology so bottom line here
for the fixes remove the barriers to
creation of these expert teams and pay
people for doing it like you do an
anatomic path of radius now here's
another one and this is a something
raised by the committee a failure to
create a work environment which permits
communication and when I was at
Vanderbilt one of the leaders of the
hospital and I often got together to
have conversations about work and and
what we showed when I showed him the
data from the red dots and the green
dots about the impact
the coagulation diagnostic management
team he said it's probably because we
bought a new instrument radiology or we
hired somebody in radiology who was
better at picking up pulmonary emboli
and I think this messaging from the top
is really important he had a real sense
that maybe pathologists and clinical lab
scientists didn't know enough clinical
information because nobody's speaking up
about it except to say a few words about
malignant or benign and and that wasn't
enough for him so he figured that we
couldn't possibly be the reason and I
think that that messaging from the top
is critical another thing that the
committee said is that the patient has
to speak up they have to say could it be
something else wait a minute I have five
more questions and I need to ask them to
you the visits are short and the poor
doctor doesn't know what factor 5 Leiden
is and they know a little bit more than
the patient does but that's not good
enough right so there has to be a system
put in place that allows for more time
to have this discussion between patient
and physician and the willingness of the
doc when necessary to have an expert
describe the patient's condition to the
patient the next issue that the
committee brought up is that we have
lots of health information technology
but it might not be doing what we really
needed to do so is there an instrument
that links up an automated lab
instrument into a lab information system
sure is there a very easy to use method
that allows me to connect to doctors in
Wyoming and Montana and North Dakota who
have blood clots for their patients and
tell them talk to them about
anticoagulants other than skype right
there's got to be a better way but this
is not the focus because it doesn't
sound like it's a big market and
nobody's doing it yet so we really need
the health information to technology
technology to do more than once in the
green boxes here the analysis and the
reporting they have to help us with all
the other things too so it requires a
major rethinking for them the other
thing is that we can create these apps
like dr.
the PTT app well we have one app that
that's huge and taking lots of work and
this is just one little chunk of it but
it's about the appropriate use of
anticoagulation and the back that the
page that the doc never sees looks this
complicated but we're turning each page
into yes and no so if you get these apps
that are yes and no they also have to be
updated every three months I look at
virtually every coagulation app and most
of them do not have the new drug addicts
a band and they have not eliminated
leppy rutten which has been off the
market for more than a year so when you
do these you have to update them on the
order of a month or two now we as you
can see the fix here is to really get
the information systems people who have
adequate adequate resources to listen to
us and say okay we need help with a
diagnostic test selection and
interpretation so another big problem is
we got to pay people for doing something
besides anatomic pathology and radiology
on the diagnostic side I do not think
it's because pathologists don't like the
detective work of clinical pathology
there's plenty of amazing things like
that ads for jilith story in
microbiology but when you don't get paid
for it it's just hard to make that
choice and therefore pathologists now
for maybe 20 years would have a hard
time if put on the spot handed a
microphone and said please explain
specificity in one sentence you have 15
seconds it would be hard for most of
them and so we just haven't taught it to
them to them it's not that it's not
important it's not that they don't want
to know it it's just that their task at
hand is very different so I think that
if we change the incentives we will get
a whole bunch of people who want to
communicate with talks about all
diagnostic testing so pay pathologists
not just for an atomic pass
but for everything in this diagnostic
arena and coagulation is not paid
compared to cancer for example so here's
another one the failure to recognize the
impact of diagnostic air both immediate
and key here is long term so this is a
hospital in Boston that lost 100 million
dollars four years in a row how big do
that well they were losing money so they
cut the number of radially radiology
Tech's and lab techs then you had to
wait an extra day for your imaging
studies in your lab tests which
increased the length of state so they
cut more text which increased the length
of stay further and finally there were
delays in diagnosis and complications
that really caused money and you got a
downward spiral so when people are
looking at the budget for 2017 which is
now that we're looking at it they could
be handicapping them for the 2018 budget
so it's hard to get a really precise
idea about an investment in a clinical
laboratory which saves large sums of
money but you just don't know how much
but if it's more than what you're paying
the person it's a good idea so there has
to be a strong partnership between the
clinical people who understand the
disorders and the administrators who
understand operations so that cost
savings alone are not the driving forces
so failure to share information is key
we have to tell people when mistakes are
made we often don't you just let it go
and doctors must avoid all these
misrepresentations that occur and and
and say look this happens because we
didn't fully complete the evaluation or
a misdiagnosis was my fault the other is
we have to educate the medical students
so we did a survey which you saw from
dr. Taylor 61 to 300 2 hours spent
teaching an atomic path eight hours on
all those troponin and coagulation tests
and often nothing for a test so people
don't study for it so I'm
left is what you learn in medical school
lots of AP and radiology and when you
graduate you have to pick among five
thousand tests and somebody's there to
read your radiology and anatomic path
does it make sense so you got to teach
people that here's what you should know
and don't get asked an expert here's a
blood clot that was in the legs started
down by the ankle got bigger and bigger
broke off went across the lungs killed a
patient with a pulmonary embolism so I
got to do this for one time at
Vanderbilt before I left and took this
current position in Texas it was a great
week and they were all case based
studies of cases that were written and
studied in different ways by the
students at Vanderbilt and so I would
ask them which of the following test is
useful and assessment of patient for a
pulmonary embolism and then they voted
with those electronic clickers and you
could say whoa who said platelet count
right so you teach them and then you get
a little information about how clot is
broken down ask them another question
get their answer teach them about
sensitivity and specificity and false
positives and negatives and why it works
and answers about negativity is a
negative d-dimer test important get
their answers what about this explaining
them a low probability for a PE somebody
who got off an airplane explaining how
much we'd save by not doing all those
imaging studies and just do a lab test
and then ask about a positive d-dimer
and tell them all the reasons why a
positive can't really tell it so we need
a required course for the medical
students in the United States and there
must be appropriate number of questions
on licensing exams so that they have to
know it now worried about implementing
the fixes before we get to the number of
medical errors it can be faster slow
here's fast you got the drugs to help
people with HIV live right and in a
short period of time 1990 up to about
2000 here we get to almost to a plateau
remarkable what about this one 14 years
this is slow to get rid of Reye's
syndrome and the treatment when your kid
has a fever
mm tylenol not aspirin that's all it
took right and it's at 14 years to do
that so we don't want to go slow on this
so let's talk about this and this is why
the work of click is so important so the
percentage of Americans experiencing
diagnostic air I took a five or six
conditions and got these numbers and
averaged them into one this is an
arbitrary choice on my part but they
were so high I didn't want to bias the
data it said this slide shows fifty-five
percent of people who had a pulmonary
embolism got a misdiagnosis thirty
percent who had a subarachnoid
hemorrhage misdiagnosis this is forty
four percent and it's a cancer study
from 1998 this is a 1996 case breast
cancer 21-percent god forbid you should
have a bipolar disorder because the
error in diagnosis is huge sixty-nine
percent and eighteen percent even for
diabetes remarkable so if you just
average those together it comes out to
thirty nine point five percent now to
think that if you go to a doctor that
would be like one out of every other
time almost or every third time you'd
have an error so let's take a look at
some of the other data well first I want
to draw your attention to how many times
do you see the doctor so before the age
of five your middle ear infections and
everything maybe three times a year then
there's that long span where it might be
just twice a year then you hit the
golden years and you show up for your
sore knee and whatever else is ailing
you so if there are about 300 visits and
half of them are diagnostic let's assume
there are about a hundred and sixty
roughly diagnostic visits for an average
American and i'm going to say here at
the bottom one out of ten makes it easy
to calculate that means could it be one
out of 16 well let's look at the data so
there were a number of studies and I
remember I put all those first set of
studies together and call that 39.5 and
I just made it 12 not overly bias the
data dr. Taylor talked about that that
journal American Board of Family
Medicine article talking about
uncertainty in
diagnosis and about fourteen fifteen
percent were on were uncertain about
picking lab tests so there's medical
error in their diagnostic air so I
reduced it a little totally arbitrary
figuring that maybe some of the guesses
might be right about a quarter when you
think of a multiple choice test then
there was a real study by her deep singh
that got a lot of attention on the
British Medical Journal quality and
safety and said it's a gross under
estimate but it's at least one out of 20
visits five percent and here's another
study recent that said 6.6 on medical
errors one point five four five
diagnostic errors so that comes out if
you average out those it's one out of
seven outpatient or inpatient encounters
has a medical error so when you look at
that that's less right then one we said
up of what one out of ten so the number
actually came out to one out of seven
with this limited amount of data now if
you ask patients have you had a medical
error it turns out two studies one in
six said they had a medical air the
other was one in 4.5 so really only
about one out of five people know
they've had a medical mistake happened
to them okay here mine so when I was ten
I was that person everybody was kneeling
down around unconscious for 10 minutes a
blow to the head from a line drive
playing baseball going from second to
third base they put me in the back of a
truck took me to a primary care doctor
who took my blood pressure and said get
lost kid you're fine right nobody
observed me nothing by it a subdural I
would have been dead miner treatment
problem I had a bad bronchitis and I got
a biostimulant because the guy said
clearing your bowels is good for
everything the third one was I had an
esophageal biopsy that was lost if and I
waited three years for my next one and
if I had metastatic or even primary
disease at that point that could have
been a life threatening I had time to
plan my funeral for the next mistake it
took 13 days to get my biopsy read the
next one I got off an airplane and
somebody said oh I gastroenteritis and
they said you could have a
I said I'm not even short of breath 70
times the radiation of an x-ray mistake
would not let them do it my mother had a
heart attack my father had a heart
attack my grandfather and his five
brothers had a heart attack and I never
got advice on any cardiovascular
protection I lost a dental implant even
though I kept saying is this gum
infected is this infected and I had to
have my jaw bone drilled into twice and
I got only half the dose of a bowel prep
before colonoscopy so I have one for fun
and I'm not going to tell you about the
other two but so far at my age I've had
ten I should expect six more when I get
to the ICU I'm going to have plenty of
opportunity because I'll have a lot of
morbidities going on at the same time so
virtually every American as a diagnostic
error the number of times is far greater
to be that to be than one so these are
the perspectives care is delivered
locally we need to bring experts in one
way or another because it's just too
Doug uncomplicated and and if we do this
the outcomes for patients and the costs
are both going down because we're going
to be able to do it better now for this
I show you this this picture because for
this one by showing you the symbol of
the marine when when you die defending
your country everybody recognizes that
you if you have made a contribution and
we spend money to recognize that and
this is what happens when you die from a
medical there right now nothing so we
have to fix it right and if you look
right now about 260,000 annual medical
deaths deaths from medical error how
much do we spend trying to estimate this
we probably spend about four hundred
dollars per deaths for medical error
trying to figure out why somebody might
have died if we recognize it I was
watching the number of dollars spent on
plane crashes that's about five thousand
dollars per death and part of the reason
is commercial right because if the same
airline keeps losing airplanes nobody's
going to ride that airplane to this
there's a business incentive and we
don't have a financial incentive
to fix the medical errors so that's
where we are that's weaving in all the
lab utilization and a medical error I
hope you found it informative thank you
very much and I'm happy to take
questions back to you Julie great Mike
dr. la posada did an excellent job we
sure appreciate what he's done for us
today now it's time for question and
answers if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now I see three
questions up already so we'll get to
those but i just want to remind people
that you just click on the green QA
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
so what I'll do is I will read dr. la
posada the first question it is how can
a particular diagnostic error be traced
back from a long-term complication so
there that's a very good question i
think that it has to be done on a
case-by-case basis let's say for example
somebody comes in with chest pain and
rid they really have cardiac ischemia
and it takes them two days to figure out
that it's cardiac ischemia and they're
treating incorrectly well what happens
when when you wait that long you lose
more myocardial so let's say that the
long term complication is serious
congestive heart failure I think that as
you trace that individual case back you
can say there was three days till I got
a diagnosis of cardiac ischemia this is
much greater than the average amount of
time across America medical error so I
think that really if you have a
particular complication what you need to
do is investigate it and say could it
have been because of diagnostic error
when the patient first presented second
one Julie
yes this next one starts with in the
real world physicians are struggling to
service more patients a day to survive
financially to keep their practices
afloat with the HMO minimal financial
contributions do you think the doctor
would have enough time to communicate
with the patient to answer all his
questions so the Institute of Medicine
committee said definitely not and and
the reason is because if you look at all
the information that's coming now we're
going to say you have a clotting
disorder and the clotting disorder is
because of antithrombin deficiency okay
it's already complicated it turns out in
a couple of years we're going to know
what the mutation is and what your
thrombotic risk is who could possibly
know that and that's why diagnosis is a
team sport and the ultimate thing would
be to take all these different
recommendations so the healthcare
information system people make it easy
for you to press 7 that's how you get a
clutter and somehow your tight into a
diagnostic management team that does
this and they're sitting there taking
cases and and we're doing this now we've
done it before at Vanderbilt done it
before it's a Mass General Hospital
we're trying to make it bigger statewide
here in Texas that's our goal over the
next couple of years so that doctors
caring for patients can just punch in by
subscription so yeah I think it's a huge
challenge and what it means is that we
have to redo the system it's not the
people next one yes the next one is it
has been well documented that
laboratories are evolving to factory
environments where three or four
laboratory scientists manage the
workload of three or more hospitals so
we have no time for making every call
for every abnormal result and I think
they mean to say I know the solution is
on education
and the question is how can we include
in education programs for physicians
this kind of subject a very important
question and I will tell you it was one
that received a fair amount of
discussion and I would like to say that
I helped promote the discussion I think
that it's amazing that doctors who are
getting laboratory tests don't
understand the how much the people know
the clinical lab scientists who are
working either at the bench PhD lab
directors pathologist those who really
know it can contribute so the problem
here is that if if you make a clinical
laboratory so small that you're barely
getting by the complete blood counts you
have no chance to do that the whole the
whole concept of helping somebody is
impossible however if there are people
who can do this as you saw diagnosis is
a team sport people should be paid for
it if you put all that together the
recommendation of the IOM committee is
build a lab with experts in areas where
you can work up a prolonged PTT these
are the tests for hypercoagulable ax t
and so by fixing one thing you don't fix
it you have to put together all these
different eight or nine recommendations
and one of them is making sure that the
clinical laboratory technologists are
part of this health care consultation
team yes Mike and we have one more
question and I haven't read it yet let
me see if I can read it has the
systematic teaching of the proper use of
diagnostic tests been integrated into
the curricula of the medical schools in
the USA if yes which universities have
done so already so i have i've taught
laboratory medicine in many different
ways at the university of pennsylvania
at harvard at vanderbilt and now at the
university of texas and i will tell you
that the survey which was just before
by the cliq group reflects what it has
been for the past 30 years a laboratory
medicine is taught by people who are
non-experts largely that is during your
experience in internal medicine when you
have your first patient who has a heart
attack somebody will mention troponin
however there's not a full discussion to
tell you whether troponin t is the same
as troponin i or to tell you what a
troponin leak is or to explain why a
fourth-generation troponin test might be
better than a first generation troponin
test or maybe it's worse because it's
harder to make a diagnosis of a heart
attack these are the critical things you
face when you're facing the patient with
chest pain in the emergency department
however the emphasis is largely on an
atomic path now I will say we have to
keep that because that's how we
understand the pathogenesis of disease
however you cannot exclude the the
teaching of laboratory medicine because
it is something that every doctor who
practices medicine does every single day
of his or her life and Mike we have
another question while the formation
formulation of a diagnostic team is
commendable how would this impact the
turnaround time on results back to the
referring physician yes that's a
question we have raised by specialty so
for example if we're asking about
somebody who had a clot and they're on
warfarin and they're going to be on
warfarin for six months there's not much
of a challenge if we get back the
results to them in one day or two won't
matter if on the other hand somebody's
in the emergency department with pupils
that are dilated and you don't know
which drug of abuse it is that's a
problem because they generally show up
at three o'clock in the morning anyhow
so there are definite turn around time
issues based upon what it is we're going
to provide advice about and I would say
we are just doing our best even in
coagulation if we see a factor eight
inhibitor and immediate emergency we
will get out of the
room and take care of it right away so
it does depend on what the test is and
yes you're absolutely right we are going
to have to figure out not only about
building a diagnostic management team
but optimizing its use so the turnaround
time is considered as part of the
optimization great Mike I have a
question and I thought we had a little
bit time although we're over people can
get off the phone if they would like but
I wanted to ask you how do you think the
IOM report will affect lab test
utilization in the US well what we
really hoped with the IOM report is that
this is now a matter for public
consumption I think up to now the issue
of diagnostic air has been a secret but
what everybody just said is that we
working in the laboratory are part of a
team everybody on the team is important
there's no reason to take somebody who
spent 30 years working in a clinical
laboratory whose expertise has been hid
under a bushel basket and leave them
there so I think that with the public
having a greater understanding of how
broken the system is and importantly how
fixable it is that they will start to
argue that we need to commit resources
to addressing this problem great Mike
and dr. la posada we really appreciate
your presentation today and what I'd
like to do is before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing for
six months from today's live event you
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
and I want to thank the audience for
attending our webinar today and also dr.
lapis Saudis so thank you again and we
hope you have a great day goodbye thanks